What's your favorite animal? Oh mom. Oh my God. She's so cute.
We brought together 17 moms.
I am a teen mom. I am a teen mom. I am a teen mom. I'm a teen mom.
I'm a teen mom. I'm a teen mom.
No one is a liar. If the group discovers who the liar is,
they'll win a cash prize. If the liar survives, they win the cash prize.
This is old man out.
Having a baby, like your life just changes like that.
I think what's going to set the mole and a real teen mom apart. Is the details,
have you lost or have you gained friends? Are you still with your baby's father?
Oh, I definitely wouldn't have known what the hell goes on during the postpartum
stage or like after birth. So off. If I do too much,
people are going to be suspicious of me and think that I'm like overdoing it.
I feel confident, but I'm nervous. The mole will probably be like a nanny,
like a big sister.
Hi, how old everyone is. Wait, the babies are us both.
I turned 18 in August and my baby's 10 months, but he turns 11 months tomorrow.
Almost a year. Oh my goodness. That's so exciting.
I am 15 and my baby is four months. I'm 19.
My daughter just turned 21 months today. I'm 17 and I've got an eight month old.
I am 19 and I have a two-year-old daughter. I just turned 18.
My daughter's two and a half. She just turned two in April.
I'm 14 and I have an eight month old and she turns one in March.
So how about you? His birth story? How long were you guys in labor?
I was in labor for 47 hours. It was miserable, but of course it was worth it.
I was in labor for 11 hours. I'm jealous. Labor is good.
Did you guys have epidurals? Did you guys go natural? I had an epidural.
I can't do natural. Did anybody get induced? Like half and half?
Like they broke my water. I didn't even want an epidural, but at like 38 hours,
I was like, I'm either gonna, yeah, I was like,
I'm going to have to have a C-section no strength left in my body.
I only got to six centimeters.
That's why I had to have a C-section your body wouldn't progress? Um,
the umbilical cord was wrapped around her neck. Say my baby.
He came out all blue and purple. It was, he didn't even cry when he came out.
I was literally so slider my baby. Didn't either when I didn't hear him cry,
I was just like, please tell me my baby. I bet your heart just drop.
They don't cry for awhile though. Like you think they'll cry,
but I've heard lots of the movies.
We just all seem like we were just.
Teen moms just chatting and having a good time.
I like hearing like everyone's stories.
Cause I know not everyone's flavor is the exact same. So it's like nice to hear.
I feel like Emma is actually a mom and I feel like, so Shauna, the other three,
they were quite quiet so far. I'm the most suspicious of Kira.
This is a total random guest. I'm so sorry, girl,
but I will have to vote for you. Emma really stuck out to me.
She is who I will be voting on. I am definitely most of Kiana.
I think I'm saying her name, right? I think I'm going to vote for Kimberly.
I don't know I'm going to go off Kimberly. I'm kind of suspicious of Kayla.
I think this round I'm going to vote up Kayla. I'm so sorry, girl.
She was just not giving me mom vibes.
The votes are in and we have a tie between Kimberly and Kayla.
So we're going into a tie breaker.
Each one of you will get 20 seconds to state your case. First up is Kayla.
So I realized that I was pregnant when I was 16,
gave birth 17 I'm 18 years old.
I'm bouncing school while raising my 10 with baby. My mom was a teen mom.
So like, it was just like really hard having to come out with that.
Cause I feel like it made it seem like I was like following her footsteps.
And she was like really disappointed about that. So that was like really hard.
I found out I was pregnant July 19 with my boyfriend.
He bought me the pregnancy test. I told my mom, well,
she found out because she noticed, cause I was really open about my periods,
her,
she made me take a pregnancy test in front of her and my dad was outside the
restroom. We told the school,
they had found resources and I'm moving to a school for pregnant teens and teen
moms.
The boats for the tie breaker are in and the teen mom eliminated in round one
is Kayla.
Hi, sorry girl. I genuinely thought she was a teen mom.
I had the boat for Kayla just because Kimberly had a strong
story. I wish I would've stayed longer. I really want to just show my baby.
She is a pretty good baby.
She only cries when she's trying to go to sleep and you will not stand up. See
right now she's learning how to use her hands and stuff. Cause she's so young.
I don't really have like her favorite things, but she does love cocoa Mellon.
Like if she sleep and I put cocoa melanin, she'll wake up and watch it.
She loves animals. This girl,
this girl is not afraid of anything. We have a bearded dragon.
Her name is saffron. The second she walks in,
nobody doesn't have a smile on their face. He's currently teething.
So he's having a lot of sleepless nights,
which is why he's actually up this late because I'm in the UK.
He is usually all around a happy little boy, giggling, smiling,
always talking and interrupting.
Her favorite thing is cocoa Mellon and she loves swatch and gloopy.
She loves to do little dance parties. What's your favorite color?
What's your favorite animal? Um, Oh,
well her very animal Elmo. Apparently her dad is not informal,
but she's still thriving. She likes eating a lot. Everything I eat,
she eats too. She crawls a lot.
She's very talkative and very friendly.
Like she won't cry with anyone
she's hungry right now.
Her favorite things are unicorns dressing up.
Being a princess you love is, huh?
It was kind of a fight to get her out of a princess dress today.
But we managed to do it right? Oh yeah.
Whenever you meet her, she just like, won't say much and she's pretty reserved.
Perfect.
I thought he was really cool. Seeing all the babies,
they all looked exactly like their moms.
Like people might suspect me because I have a toddler and the rest of them had
like babies who were like super attached to them.
I don't know if we've got them all now. I don't think Kayla was the moment.
I still have a really weird suspicion about Kimberly.
I'm just going to go with Kim. Really? No valid explanation.
I am going to go with Emma this time. Like I did before.
Just because in this situation against the other girls,
other girls are kind of a little bit calmer than her.
If I had to vote for someone now.
I think I would vote for it. Yeah.
I want to say I'm kind of suspicious of Kiana.
So I figured out how to say Kian his name.
And I say I'm still most suspicious about birth when I'm scared.
I knew it. I thought it was gonna be me.
I didn't really have too much to say about my child because she is so young.
All the other moms had a lot to say, but we will see,
I had thought I was pregnant for like a couple of weeks,
but I was kind of in denial. And so my boyfriend, my now fiance,
but he was my boyfriend at the time. Congratulations. Thank you.
And so we had stopped at seven 11 to grab some candy and some snacks to sneak
into the movie theater. I just got like the cheapest pregnancy test.
And then I took it in the movie theater bathroom. When I came out,
he just could read my face and he said, you're pregnant. Aren't you? And I said,
yep. And he goes, well, we'll figure it out. You've never broken up.
He's always been the best dad. So I was so good.
And I hid my pregnancy. My parents found out, yeah, surprise.
Literally everybody was like, Oh yeah,
but I didn't show like at all.
And I just wear a sweatshirt and I worked two jobs the whole time I was
pregnant so we could support her in. Yeah, that's my story. My mom,
I actually got grounded and I was in trouble and she took away my phone.
I did a text, my friend on messenger on my computer.
And I was telling her that I had like a bunch of symptoms.
Cause she also a teen mom and she said, yeah, you're pregnant.
And my mom had seen the texts coming through my phone.
So she read them and just let loose on me.
And then once my dad found out, he was the most supportive.
My dad is like very religious. So he's like things happen for a reason,
but I stay in supportive parents.
One thing that happened when I was in high school, I wrote a lot of judgment.
So I had to move to online school and some people actually TV in my house.
I was pregnant. That was horrible and row
and Whoa, that's.
Terrible. I'm so sorry. I had to go through that.
It wasn't in June. I was getting period cramps, but period,
wasn't coming. So I Googled that up.
And the first thing that came up was pregnancy.
I had told my boyfriend and he came over to my house,
but this was in July and he brought the pregnancy test and I took it and he was
happy. But um, I kind of had a blank expression on my face.
I didn't really know what to think. I didn't want to believe it.
I'm so emotional.
I cry when other people cry and my parents found out in
August because they noticed that I wasn't getting my
period. I told a couple of friends and they told me to abort,
but I knew I wasn't going to do that.
Me and my boyfriend have been together for almost three years in February.
Everyone knows my baby now. And
Oh girl. Yeah. That's it like,
I'm really happy with how my life is right now.
I love that for anything. Okay.
So I was 15. When I found out I was pregnant.
The first person I told was obviously my boyfriend, whose name is duck.
We didn't plan it. But he was like, no, you've got to keep that.
We're amazing together. We're going to start a life together.
Both my parents were really, really supportive.
They explored so many roots of what I could have gone through.
And it was amazing to have that support, especially from parents.
But then about five months down the pregnancy line,
me and my boyfriend actually broke up. We completely blocked teacher though.
We didn't talk to each other enough, saw each other on his due date.
He actually got back in contact with me and then we got back together and then
our son was born four days later. Um, and we're still together now.
So.
No, I was pregnant at 15.
My school is like a high school that also has an infant lab in the school,
which is like a daycare type thing.
So they have a teen clinic where they like do like pregnancy tests,
like STD checks, like literally everything.
One day I went there after school with one of my good friends and I found out I
was pregnant there.
The doctor just kind of walked into the room and she was like, stood there.
So I'm like, Oh boy, like, there we go. Yeah.
I kind of knew like from her like expression that I was pregnant and me and my
boyfriend were only together for, it was like a month at the time.
And he was 14 and I was 15.
He was just mainly really scared to tell his parents. Yeah.
My parents were super supportive though. My mom was a teen mom herself.
Thankfully the school I go to has an infant lab, a daycare thing.
I'm able to bring her to school with me still. And this year is my last year.
Woo. I'll wait.
To graduate. Oh my goodness. I'm going to be the first in my family.
It's going to be so it's amazing.
I live the mole is a really good actor or we already got it.
I'm not suspicious of any line. I don't,
unfortunately I'm going to vote Shanna out this round.
I really hate to because she seems really nice. If we didn't vote out the movie,
I'm going to be mad. I am suspicious of Kira and I'm going to be voting for her.
I'm still very, very suspicious of Kimberley in the 20 seconds about me.
Like her tie breaker. I swear. She said her parents found out,
bought her pregnancy test because I have to vote for one.
I'm going to say Kimberly, just for the fact that she had the least.
Detailed. She was the least descriptive. I think I'm going to vote for Kimberly.
I'm so sorry. I had no idea who to vote for. I feel bad. I'm sorry.
I feel like maybe I don't know. I guess when I'm washing her,
whenever I told the story.
Give me a thumbs up. If you want to continue the game, if not,
give me a thumbs down and you think you caught them all and want to end the game
right now.
This is so nerve wracking.
If the color that shows up is green, you all win. If it's red, the fake team,
mom is still in the game and you all lost in three.
Two. What
[inaudible], who was it?
The game is over and the teen moms have one.
We're also going to be gifting them the akin to experience where they'll get to
pick their favorite basics from our new interactive apparel brand.
I would like the mall to please reveal yourself in three.
I knew it. I knew it
did good. Good job. That is one cute baby though. Oh my goodness.
Whose baby is it? And my mom's baby.
I knew it. When you go out to people think it's yours. Um, sometimes yeah.
I babysit him a lot.